[Music]
[Music]
so purchases of less than $100 that have
most improved my life in recent memory
because there are many purchases of less
than hundred dollars there a few right
off the bat sneak preview here there
okay so number one is this hat this is
the Sitka Dakota beanie and it's camo
just so people don't see your head when
you're walking around you look like the
Headless Horseman
and your turquoise shirt but extremely
comfortable hat that for whatever reason
I Knight I can't properly explain this I
can wear say in warmer temperatures like
60 just cuz I don't have much coverage I
can also wear it sub-freezing and it
works in both environments I first got
exposed to this it gives a hunting brand
it's kind of like the the Lululemon the
most comfortable clothing in the hunting
world really high quality gear when I
was in Colorado and I travel with this
everywhere I also use it as a murse man
purse so I'll stick say a piece of
recording equipment into this hat to
protect it because it's semi pad and so
this travels with me constantly that's
number one might as well show you this
number two which is a sprays ink this is
there's-- ink spray which is a zinc
gluconate and I use this for immune
support so this travels in the side of
my backpack and I wall spray like been a
cough but five or six sprays around the
mouth and I will do this two or three
times probably per day when I'm
traveling and I've found it as it
appears at least to me to make a
substantial difference if there are a
lot of people getting sick and
continuing to get sick coughing and so
on on a trip or on a plane this helps me
not to succumb so this is always with me
the next one that is always with me and
all these items travel with me 24/7
effectively they live in my backpack
this is the rubs device and no it is not
a massage parlor with black windows it
is what looks like a golf ball and it
has these little nubs on it it was
gifted to me
this is very very cheap it's like six
dollars gifted to me by Amelia Boone so
thank you Amelia
who is a four-time world champion in
obstacle course racing and you roll out
your feet or your hands or your forearms
in my case with this device and it is
incredible how much it relieves pain
throughout the body if you just roll out
your feet properly which is something I
picked up
not only from Amelia Boone but from Edie
Cowan who is the most successful
legendary power lifter in the history of
the world I think he ded lifted 901
pounds at 220 or something insane like
that and a lot of back pain leg pain in
my experience goes away when you just
rub out your feet so if I land at a
hotel or when I wake up after much
travel I use this on the feet next up we
have this device this isn't the most
interesting angle though that is the
most interesting angle this is the
Logitech keys to go keyboard and it
holds a charge for a very very long time
and I stick this in the laptop pocket
why because I like to work and say
restaurants I like to type I like to
brainstorm in restaurants but I don't
want to have a laptop out or if my
laptop has a problem and I can't use it
I still want to be able to type and not
poke at my iPhone screen so I will take
my iPhone lean it against say a glass of
iced tea or wine or whatever and then I
will pair it to this keyboard and I can
type an entire chapter out it's really
cool and people don't even notice
necessarily that I'm working they just
think I'm a crackhead staring at my iced
tea for two hours straight all right
last up and this is increasingly
important as I travel to louder and
louder cities let's say in some cases is
the following
max pillow soft silicon putty and this
is what it looks like these are earplugs
and they are not foam and what this
allows you to do is
sleeeeep very very very well and that
includes laying on your side so what
happens if you say roll up foam earplugs
to come in here and they lay in their
side you feel like you have a nerf ice
pick being jabbed into your eardrum
which is not very comfortable and I find
these two also dampen sound more
effectively than foam typically
fantastic so those are a handful of the
purchases less than hundred dollars that
have most impacted my life and continue
to they travel with me 24/7 hey guys if
you're enjoying the tips and tactics and
how-to on this channel or in the podcast
the Tim Ferriss show I made this for you
try the mentors short advice from the
best in the world this is the book that
I wanted to read so I went out and I put
it together created a dream list 130 of
the best at what they do people who are
icons legends and ask them all the same
questions these are people in some cases
I wanted to reach out to my whole life
ranges from many many billionaires
cofounders of every company imaginable
elite athletes ranging from surfing to
tennis to powerlifting everything else
country stars actors directors and you
can spot the pattern so some of my
friends have said this is the easiest to
read most useful book that I've put
together yet so check it out tribe of
mentors dot-com you can find sample
chapters the whole list of mentors
everything tribe mentors calm